à ce
jeu vous propose pour terminer ce
journal de partir en compagnie d'éric
perrin et de patrick voit dans les
coulisses du tournage dans le nord du
film le plus cher du cinéma français
film réalisé par claude berri un budget
de 160 milliards de francs budget
colossal à l'image de l'oeuvre adapté
germinal d'emile zola des acteurs très
célèbre depardieu miu miu jean carmet ou
encore renault pour son premier rôle au
cinéma mais aussi des centaines de
figurants originaires du
nord/pas-de-calais
complainte du vent sur la mine
d'arenberg fermé depuis quatre ans
complainte oublier pour quelques
semaines où le corps on reprend vie
grâce au tournage de germinal toujours
méticuleux claude berri peaufine chaque
scène visite des bourgeois chez les
mineures rencontre de deux mondes en
arrière-plan distants les figurants en
arrière-plan mais omniprésent chômeurs
ou anciens mineurs les petits-enfants de
germinal redonne vie à leur passé berry
tenait à tourner dans le nord
non parce que ça me paraissait évident
je me voyais pas faire le film ailleurs
qu'ici je pense que
même pas les appeler ses figurants tous
ces mineurs qui sont le coeur du film
donne donne l'âme
dans l'âme du film je ne sais pas je ne
me voyais pas passer des mois en pologne
avec
avec dix ont un coeur un choeur polonais
il fallait vraiment que ce soit ça se
passe dans le nord
à quelques centaines de mètres du
tournage le puits numéro 3 le plus
profond fermés comme les autres entre
deux prises certains reviennent voir
l'endroit où ils ont travaillé mémoire
des gestes
quand un mineur se présente il ajoute
généralement deux nombres voici au
volant de la locomotive petit michel 32
- 670 comprenait 32 ans domine jusqu'à -
670 mètres sous terre
est encore plus grosse que celle là
c'est là qu'il m'a retourné
les clubs pas dans l'air
il y avait le volant des ducs ou que je
parte ou
le fils de michel lui aussi sur le
tournage histoire de famille mémoire des
souffrances mémoire d'une culture
ouvrière mémoire qui donne relief à
l'entreprise d'illusions qui est un film
6 mhz et de joie d'exister
extraordinaire malgré l'adversité parce
que beaucoup ont cessé de travailler
avant l'âge et puis beaucoup
il veut donc dans la souffrance parce
qu'ils ont des thés des séquelles
pulmonaires j'ai terriblement dur joie
de vivre malgré tout grâce à cette
amitié cette ambiance perdu de la mine
que tous retrouvent sur le tournage
qu'il partage avec les comédiens comme
renault germinal peut compter sur un
acteur irremplaçable est vrai il
s'appelle le nord